This one is really interesting.
We have another example of occasional voice
of reason on Fox News, occasional actual journalist
on Fox News, Chris Wallace, calling out another
Republican official for their just obvious,
blatant, pathetic hypocrisy.
This time the target, the victim.
I don't know what you would call them.
The mark is Texas Republican Governor Greg
Abbott, who said nothing when Donald Trump
was president about all of the alleged sexual
abuse at migrant shelters when Donald Trump
was in office.
But now all of a sudden that Joe Biden is
in office, Greg Abbott is claiming to care
about allegations of sexual assault at these
migrant detention centers.
So let's get right into it.
And then after this, I'll remind you of something
very similar happened with Chris Wallace just
a couple of weeks ago.
We'll look at that a little bit later.
Here's the clip of Chris Wallace and Greg
Abbott.
Let's talk about those dire consequences.
You made news this week reporting that there
are cases of sexual abuse at the Frieman.
Coliseum in San Antonio, Texas, that houses
right now more than six hundred children,
but the head of a nonprofit that provides
legal services to immigrants said this.
The only reason why Abbott is now acting like
he cares about the children and these facilities
is for political reasons.
Governor, there were thousands of complaints
of sexual abuse at migrant shelters during
the Trump years.
Not to say that what's going on now is right,
but we couldn't find one instance of you complaining
and pulling that out when President Trump
was president.
Sure, there are multiple differences between
what happened in the Trump administration
and what is happening now.
First, the Trump administration remained in
constant communication with me and with my
office and let us know what was going on.
Second, I saw reports about exactly what you're
talking about and saw that those reports were
filed with federal agencies.
The one that I talked about earlier this past
week were reports that were filed with state
agencies, the Texas Health and Human Services
Commission and the Department of Protective
and Child Services, which is basically the
Child Protective Services.
And so we have a duty to respond to any complaint
about child sexual abuse in Texas, as well
as to investigate it.
And that's exactly what I did to make sure
it was addressed.
So Abbott says there are multiple differences.
When Trump was president, there was really
only one difference, which is Trump was president
then and Joe Biden is president now, that
all of the other differences that Greg Abbott
cites there really distinctions with no practical,
substantive difference.
And if it's true.
That now Greg Abbott is being notified about
this, and when it was Trump, he wasn't being
notified, I would look at whether the reason
for that is in itself politically motivated.
Every time this happens, they always come
up with meaningless semantic distinctions
that lack any substantive difference.
And that's exactly what Greg Abbott did.
Now, let me remind you, the last one of these
that Chris Wallace did was a couple of weeks
ago, and he interviewed Republican Senator
Tom Cotton.
And Wallace asked Tom Cotton, listen, you
know, now you're complaining that with Biden's
covid stimulus, prison inmates received stimulus
money.
They also got stimulus money during Donald
Trump's first covid stimulus and Donald Trump's
second covid stimulus.
And you voted for those.
And Tom Cotton came up similarly with a meaningless
response that has distinctions that really
are of no substantive importance whatsoever.
Take a look.
Here is one of your other complaints about
the covid relief bill.
Take a look, sir.
Look how crazy some of the Democratic ideas
are, I mean, they had a chance on Saturday
morning to stop chicks from going to prisoners,
from going to the Boston bomber, for instance.
And on that vote, they declined.
Every single Democrat wanted to continue the
practice of sending checks to prisoners.
But, Senator, under two previous covid related
bills that you supported and voted for and
that president runs on prisoners also got
checks in those bills.
Well, Chris, that was obviously never Congress's
intent.
The Trump administration, IRS and Treasury
Department did not send checks to prisoners.
Liberal advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge that they had to last
month was that far.
This month was the first time we ever had
a simple up or down vote on whether those
checks should go to prisoners.
And the simple fact is that every Democrat
voted to keep sending checks to prisoners.
I don't think that's a smart idea.
I suspect most Americans don't either.
Again, there is no defense other than to say,
you know, Chris, that's right.
I'm playing politics.
That's the truth.
That's the real answer.
During covid stimulus, one and two, it wasn't
our intent, he says.
But this time, Democrats did want prison inmates
to get the money.
And then he says, this is the first time we
had an up or down vote and it passed.
Well, that's because you guys controlled the
Senate before and you didn't want an up and
down vote on it, but the up and down votes
would have essentially been the same.
Both times, it's always deflection.
It's pointing fingers.
And that's really the Trump mantra that a
lot of these Republicans have adopted and
perfected in some sense.
So as far as Chris Wallace goes, good for
him.
You know, we've talked before Wallace tries
to find we can all find fault with any cable
news, talking head if we want to.
I get the impression that Chris Wallace's
intentions are generally good.
That being said, there is the counterpoint
that whether Chris is well intentioned or
not.
Acting in good faith or not, his presence
at Fox News provides cover, a sort of smoke
screen for people like Tucker Carlson and
Sean Hannity and for Fox News to say, listen,
we've got a lot of different things.
We have Chris Wallace and we have Tucker Carlson
and we have Sean Hannity.
I take the position that it doesn't matter.
And what I mean by that is Chris Wallace is
asking many of the right questions.
And sure, he will be used by Fox News for
Fox to be able to say we're fair and balanced.
We have news and opinion.
We have things that are more critical of the
Biden administration support, whatever.
Some of these right wingers will see it.
And by math, some fraction might realize,
wow, these Republicans are really hypocrites.
And Wallace is the exception on Fox.
He's not the rule.
I get that.
But I continue to believe that his presence
does more good than harm overall, much like
Shepard Smith while he lasted until he ended
up just bailing out on Fox News.
In terms of Abbott and Cotton and all of these
guys, they're dangerous.
They're completely amoral, if not immoral.
Greg Abbott's lieutenant governor, Dan Patrick,
you might remember, was the guy who early
in the pandemic said, listen, grandma would
sacrifice herself for the economy by which
he meant the stock market.
So all of these guys have a very similar,
I guess we call a lack of a moral compass.
Tom Cotton never saw a double standard.
He could get away from their terrible and
any opportunity to possibly expose them for
what they are, even if it's coming during
the exception to the rule on Fox News with
Chris Wallace.
I think it's a good thing if you disagree
with me, let me know if you think the presence
of someone like Wallace is a net negative.
I'm open to having my mind changed, but you're
going to have to change it.
Let me know your thoughts and we'll have more
on this and other such Fox News incidents
on our Instagram page.
You can find us on Instagram at David Pakman
show.